I went to I can't believe I'm talking
about this I meant to talk about this on
the podcast ever since I started I was
gonna talk you know but I this is where
the reason I I didn't forget about it
it's just the special one so well after
it that I started think about the
special lab but I my I met Eminem we
hung out for two hours and it was
[ __ ] unbelievable yeah you don't know
this so yeah dude my agents and him were
and them they're eight people were going
back and forth and they were like Krista
can be in Detroit does em want to come
to the show and they're like yeah
definitely and then they were in New
York and so they were like why don't
wasn't Christians come by the studio
when we land so they were in the studio
and Michael anoche and Zach are like I'm
above me I was always a huge Eminem fan
growing up I mean all that [ __ ] but Mike
Eminem was Mike's Idol and still is and
so Mike's like oh my god I'm gonna
[ __ ] I talk about all week so
annoying I was like man maybe I
shouldn't have invited you he's like
I'll be fine I'll be fine so we get
there and Zach and and we get in there
and we and we show up and Eminem is just
sitting there like come on it they come
on in and then I we walk into the room
and and sitting there and Eminem stands
up and goes like this flapping around
like a babkin to me and I'm like okay
this is the craziest [ __ ] thing
already he's doing my impression to me
of him and he was like what's up man and
then we sat down and I'm sitting on the
same couch as Eminem and we're all
talking and he was like man you killed
that impression man it was so funny he
was like it was amazing and the one in
the garage where you're at where you're
out of breath
dude that's hilarious he's like cuz I
get out of breath sometimes I was just
like it was so mind-blowing and he is
let me just say this about him i sat
with him for two hours and in like 35
minutes in I go I did the obligatory
kind of like nice guy like well we don't
want to take up too much your time like
so and he was the real egg now we're
just chilling hangout like alright I
said my [ __ ] piece so we were hanging
out and he was talking about hip hop
talking about rap you know we can't we
wanted to obviously I I'm gonna do less
of the talking if I'm sitting with them
and him I want him to do most of the
talking and and he was just in the best
way in the best way
he was just the most normal cool guy you
know you don't know you know these
[ __ ] icons these legends you know you
meet them and sometimes they have this
air where it's like you're you're lucky
to be here dude he didn't feel that way
I didn't feel that way at all and it was
so cool and refreshing he was just a
real mature kind of cool dude talked a
lot about hip-hop talked about a lot
about who his favorite rappers were and
we talked about comedy a lot we talked
about different comedians we talked
about you know my act what I'm talking
about and it was just a trip man but he
mentioned a bunch of his favorite rapper
as you mentioned you know I mentioned
Tupac and Biggie and jay-z and all those
guys but man it was I don't even know
what to say do it I kept thinking about
it the next day it was just so cool and
then they were like well let's get a
picture and we got a picture and I
posted it to Instagram and I was like
dude I just it's one thing to [ __ ] do
this thing in the in in my in my
driveway and make this video and then it
went viral and it's nothing for you to
share and tweet it it's another thing
for you to put me on the song I was like
but this is so cool
and it was just so nice you to have us
come in man it really means a lot and
I've always been such a big fan of yours
and he was like thank you man I really
appreciate it I mean so [ __ ] weird
man like I mean you know I meet
everybody I you know I meet everybody I
mean I've met [ __ ] everybody I lie I
met Jim Carrey I've met [ __ ] all the
you know that was my idol when I was a
kid Jim Carrey and it's just like it's a
trip man to me it's kind of a trip to
meet somebody to out of the like I don't
really care about music but I know a lot
about hip-hop and I love hip-hop and it
was cool to meet him because I I've
listened to his music so [ __ ] much
man so shout-out to everyone who made
that happen Tracy over there - that was
kind of dealing with everything did that
was Tracy's so sweet and all the other
guys that were over there - his tour
manager and then this other producer was
there too and Mike Lee no Chi and Zac
Tonko via was there
so what else happened at the what else
was he there was one part where he was
like talking about some somebody that
was like talking [ __ ] about him and he
was talking to us in conversation and
Eminem was like you don't even know what
I'm doing when I'm rapping and it doing
what we don't even know what I'm doing
when I'm rapping I'm using syllables
intricate Dib and he started rapping in
the middle of while he was talking to us
and it was [ __ ] unbelievable do it I
was like on the couch with this guy and
he's rapping talking to me rapping
telling me something in a rap and it all
made sense
it was [ __ ] insane it was such
imagine that dude being on the same
characters Eminem I need to do in that
[ __ ] I was like whatever this life I
have this [ __ ] career that I've built
out of [ __ ] making dick jokes and you
know I mean just being silly and having
a silly goose time dude
and telling you [ __ ] live rips
and now I'm sitting on the couch with a
[ __ ] mmm and he's rapping to me Hey
and he didn't even know that in the
Sprinter van on the way from [ __ ]
Pennsylvania to Detroit that I drank so
much coffee we had to pull over to the
side of road that I had to [ __ ] in
someone's yard he didn't even know that
and yes that happened a week ago